[Music]
all right we are live on the YouTube and
joining me today is an author a public
speaker a digital detox er and the
daughter of the greatest stand-up comic
of all time Kelly Carlin welcome back to
the Reuben report in the real home of
the Reuben report to this I don't know
where we were last time we did this we
were another studio we're far away in a
long car ride from my house is all I
remember yes this is a little closer to
your house it's freeway adjacent as I am
to in my house so I should also note
that we are good friends I think people
are gonna see that
yeah the course of the next hour first
off how annoyed are you at me that I
even referenced your father the great
George Carlin in the intro because I
know this is sort of it's like the most
wonderful thing that you know someone
could have or at least from the outside
and one that does comedy and also
something that you've tried to escape in
a certain way and create your own thing
and we talked about it last time and
this is what your your book is about
yeah and all that yeah what I want to
smack me right before we start no I
don't want to smack you know because I
you know I've been doing a lot of work
on this lately and what it's come down
to is this is who I am this is a part of
who I am this is how the world will
always on some level see me and see the
filter of me and yet my job is to unhook
from that and really understand that
that's just a thing that happens and if
I'm chasing after it or fighting against
it then I'm in some sort of exhausting
relationship with it yeah and really
what I've been doing lately is like what
is it like what am I about what's what's
the big conversation I want to have with
the world now and it's been funny
because I've been circling around back
to where I was 10 years ago before my
dad died actually and picking up those
pieces of myself that was ready to have
a big conversation with the world but I
didn't have all the things that I have
now which were actually
I could only have received by fully
embracing my father's legacy and walking
through the shadow of all of that by
doing the solo show and doing the memoir
and kind of trust falling into the arms
of fans and his peers you know but I had
to I had to do all of that to really
then say all right am I ready as an
adult and as a daughter to put that down
and really be in perspective with it in
a healthy way yeah so I am now it's
funny because I don't want to spend too
much time talking about that but I think
there's something particularly unique
with your situation because it's not
like you could take any big celebrity
and take their child and okay they're an
actor they're a musician whatever but
your dad was it was so directly related
to truth yeah like telling the truth
yeah and that's why he holds a special
place pretty much for every stand-up
comic but really culturally and all that
and especially in a time now and I think
this will relate to a lot of things
we're gonna talk about yeah we're we're
sort of post truth everyone up there
true where stand-up is kind of weird
right now and so much it's like I think
that probably makes your situation yeah
and why you why you wrote the book which
I know it was you know such a deeply
personal experience you know that it
just makes you particularly unique and
then I'm only gonna ask you one other
thing about yeah and and I think the
thing that I have claimed for myself
around this is that being a Carlin when
I walk into a room I have permission to
speak big truth and that's a nice card
to have these days it's an amazing card
to have and it's one I'm learning to
physically embody and mentally embody
and sometimes the big truth is nothing
about the truth that my father would
have been talking about but it's the
truth as I you know the one that I want
to hand people and one of the things
that I handed people by doing my solo
show and writing my story as a book is
the big truth that even though my father
was the truth teller on stage as a
family we had a really
a dysfunctional relationship with truth
because we were a family of addictive
addicts you know and so when you're a
family of addicts and dysfunction truth
is a whole other thing you know and that
was like the scariest but most
empowering thing for me to do with my
story was to say to his fans yes okay
he's the truth teller you've got him on
the pedestal and now here's the father
and the husband and the artist who like
it like the rest of us you know had
uncomfortable moments didn't how to
speak the truth to each other all the
time
you mean these people that we don't
really know that our performers aren't
always perfect human beings is that why
you're trying to tell I have some bad
news for you yes and that's been sort of
my fat I mean it's it's really
interesting because I went to grad
school in the early aughts as we like to
call them and when I came out of grad
school I you know I got my masters in
uni in psychology
we're gonna go into that a little bit
but studying the power of archetypes and
the gods and the goddesses and mythology
and all of that and seeing that
celebrity in our culture has kind of
taken over the part of our brain that we
used to use to worship gods you know
those of us in the secular world who
don't believe in the big guy with the
beard in the sky thing and so I've I've
always been fascinated by how we de humo
NIH's these people we put them up on
this pedestal and then what we love to
do in our culture is to bring them down
to remind them that they're human and to
say like hey I'm human - [ __ ] you were
equal you know so this is a whole little
game we play with this but yeah and it's
and it was kind of scary for me the
first few years after my dad died when I
knew that I wanted to speak some
possibly unpopular truths about my dad I
mean luckily I'm not like Mackenzie
Phillips
nothing weird like that happened in my
life but it was scary for me to come up
against people who I thought well I'm
gonna be disappointing these people
enjoy yeah that's why I think this case
even though I know you the best I have a
couple friends in similar situations
like you but but that this one where his
relationship was so close to truth
that it's like people would want to
protect him like a religious figure
which the irony related to everything he
thought about religion everything when I
started encountering the Atheist
community I mean that's what I saw was
he was on t-shirts and and there was
this this worshipping of him and I kept
reminding them you to find it a little
strange that you're worshiping the
person like you do you see the mental
gymnastics you're doing here in order to
do that you know so yeah
which you know we've done some atheist
events together I want to talk a little
bit about that from there too so one
other quick thing on him so I've told
you this story but I think it'll relate
to everything else we're going to talk
about I want of all the things that I
saw your dad on and all the specials and
all that stuff I saw him on the view
once and I think it was probably his
maybe he's one and only appearance on
the view but he was talking about the
pain that a comic has to have but I
think he was really describing it as the
pain that anyone would have yeah that
you have to have that pain for a while
and then if you don't learn to own that
pain it will destroy you and this is why
we see so many comics that either become
drug addicts or alcoholics or self
destructing the zillion other ways yeah
and for me it really helped change me I
was like oh this is the guy I idolized
and here and I was you know I was
closeted I was doing drugs I was yeah it
was just a mess a night and it did sort
of register something for me so I think
I've told you that publicly but yeah I
just wanted to put it out there right
yeah and that thing about owning our
pain I think is a something we're not
trained for here in America hide it
blame someone else
yeah and chase after the next hit yeah
of something whether it's progress or
the next million dollars or whatever
version your American Dream comes in you
know or it's the next swipe on the app
or the next tweet or did I get it now it
seemed do I get a like do I get a heart
do a thing that all that [ __ ] crap
but we are not trained as little people
and not as adults and there's knowing
there's no incoming communication about
then it's okay to a fail to feel pain to
death we don't talk about death in this
culture we don't talk about sickness I
mean we do more now I mean people you
know who like go through cancer you can
talk about cancer now we're even like 20
years ago whispers it was still like the
c-word you know and now it's a different
c-word yeah conservatives yeah you know
it's one of those seven ones I believe
but and you know when my mom died 20
years ago and that was the first time as
like my in my adult life that I faced
some big like loss in my life and it
changed me because I'd always because
because we push away loss so much in our
culture we don't know how to metabolize
it and move through it and when my mom
died instead of me like falling apart
and like ending up in a padded cell at
UCLA psych ward which I'd always
imagined for sure was gonna happen
pretty great place there yeah
why you gotta go do good UCLA is very
nice but instead it showed me a strength
I have and that in my brokenness and in
my grief I did not fall down an endless
pit I mean it was painful I mean as
grief is physically painful and I was
kind of dysfunctional for a few years
but I I felt like I had been like
tempered in some way like I'd gone
through a fire and come out the other
side of it stronger and I I don't think
you know I think about kids these days
kids these days but you think about like
how everyone gets a blue ribbon and all
that kind of stuff and nobody's learning
to metabolize failure or disappointment
or anything like that and we're just and
you need
what they're part of the human
experience you know we can't you know
it's this whole idea like the AKOP the
American economy and how it's like every
year it has to like grow grow grow grow
grow well the only thing that grows all
the time is like a cancer and and so we
have this false notion that only up is
good and and I'm here to lie I mean one
of the things I do when I I've been
teaching lately will you talk about that
is that I I have a section where I talk
about sitting with difficult emotions
you know or I have a death and dying
week we talked about that you know and
it's funny like a few less people show
up live that week maybe I'll listen to
that on my own time you know or maybe
I'll skip that week but the the ability
to sit with uncomfortableness I think
would do not all of us even all of us
personally a lot of good but just as a
country a hell of a lot of good too
right and probably people of all time
probably never dealt with those
uncountable things that well but now we
can distract ourselves so easily no on
the phone that it makes that much easier
okay so here's the one question about
your dad and then we're not going to
talk them yeah what do you think he
would make of the madness right now just
the general state the politics
that's the worst quote I know it's the
worst way I know it's the worst question
anyway but do you learn so Alfred
rephrase it's like do you think he would
be throught like creatively do you think
he'd be thriving yeah I think that I
think I mean it was always of two minds
anyway he was I mean he was of one
essential being and one mind in general
like when he would say you know oh you
think I'm kidding I'm a comedian you
think I'm kidding no I really believe
this [ __ ] he really did I mean he really
did believe the species was gonna hit a
cul-de-sac
yeah and we were in a cul-de-sac and
we're circling the drain he didn't know
how long that would take but he believed
that because of greed basically and not
having empathy for your fellow man so I
think he in some ways probably saw this
coming I mean I I tell people all the
time when they ask me this I say look I
don't know I mean I think he would hate
Trump I mean Trump represents everything
my father stood again
you know just the golf part white male
rich businessman narcissistic just the
hole and the part of New York that my
dad just you know my dad came from the
Upper West Side streets of New York nine
hundred and twenty first so which is now
George Carlin way which is George Carlin
way so he he everything about Trump he
would have hated and his and especially
his racism my father was a man who from
day one on earth for me was all about
you know everything this country has
ever done is oppressed people of a
different skin color
you know we massacred the Indians and
then we shipped in black people you know
all of that so a huge soft soft heart
for minorities and and the underdog but
the chaos of it he would have I'm sure
yeah you know and he didn't like to do
politics in the sense of like everyone
else making you know I don't know if he
you know every once in a while he'd
bring up right he didn't kind of
high-level he did sort of philosophic
Polly yeah picture you know and if he
did if he brought up Bush and Dick
Cheney you know it's because he talked
about the bush and the dick and all that
kind of some you know it was a great you
know the the pink rockets and penises in
the Gulf War or whatever it was yeah but
you know his thing was he said when
you're born you're born with a ticket to
the Freak Show and when you're born in
America you're you get a front-row seat
yeah and that thing that has sustained
me these last two years because because
you were literally born into it yeah I
mean in the name yeah and and just being
able to see it as a freak show yeah to
have my own personal politics and my own
desires for the country and the
direction and and the panic of that not
happening and then but also seeing that
this is if we can see if we survive it
and I know we will is a really good
thing for the country and that we're
having a
it's all out on the table no like if you
want to know about what this country's
been doing for 200 years well word we're
in it now and everyone's talking about
it because it's racism and misogyny and
greed and corruption in politics and
money you know I mean I hope that's the
next big conversation you know that we
can all have the big messy one is you
know money and corruption let's go there
you know yeah so we'll see because
money's everything in this country but
we'll shave we'll save the money in
corruption for our necks sit down but if
anyone wants anything else on your dad
it is all in this book yeah please which
mine will post to the link yeah yeah
hello and now let's talk about so much
yeah okay so I thought the reason I
wanted to I wanted first up we did this
two and a half years
that's impossible insane we're both
getting very old yeah but putting aside
those two and a half years yeah the
things that we've talked about privately
for the last two minutes are the things
that I've slowly been trying to
incorporate into the show things that
I've been trying to incorporate into my
life things that respect the
conversation that I'm having here so
first off your your big on the
unplugging movement yeah I think at this
point is a movement just getting off
line sometimes yeah doing the digital
detox you're teaching some webinars on
this my chronic Lee I'm teaching
webinars about unplugging I mean it here
we are doing it oh yeah this is the
technology we have and this is how you
reach people yeah what does this make us
right Hippocrates of the highest order I
don't know what it makes us complicated
human exactly but you know my audience
knows I I did Auguste completely off the
gallery with no electronics and no
nothing and I came back to the chameleon
box I've been trying to do it on the
weekends but I'm failing I'd say at
least 50% of the time yeah basically
trying to what was it that spur that
spurred this in you that was like men
there's something really wrong here
yeah a weary activist I think it's it
was two things one of which was you know
ten years ago smartphones came into
existence and all of these social media
apps came into existence and we at the
beginning all of us were like oh my god
this thing takes a picture and you could
look up the works of Shakespeare on it I
mean it's just like this is a [ __ ]
baby Jesus miracle right here you know
amazing in like Oh social media oh my
god I'm talking to strangers and look at
this and I'm like I found my voice on
social media I mean that was the first
place I went and had a platform in a
stage to say hey this is my opinion
about something outside of my house and
my friends you know so it was it same
here and I slipped on us together
Twitter brought us together
exactly Twitter exactly and I think that
was all amazing and then about five
years into it about five years ago I
felt the sudden like and part of that
was the 24/7 of the technology but also
how I was engaging with it which is I
was completely George Carlin's daughter
online mm-hmm and I had a podcast and I
had my own voice there but 99% of the
time I was getting every day I was
getting pictures of my dead father or
videos of my dead father or his name
being put in front of me and I didn't
know what to do about that because I was
like well I can't say no to this because
I signed up for this I'm writing a book
about this I have a solo show I mean
this is my own [ __ ] fault how dare I
and yet in the summer of 2016 I was in
yoga I was having a very la moment I was
in yoga in corpse pose huh literally
laying there and it was like May and I
thought what do I really need in my life
right now and I thought I need to get
away for the summer I'd done my book I'd
done publicizing it I didn't have to be
promoting myself online which is just
and I thought I'm going to do this for
three months I'm going to unplug from
the social media tether and and thus
this device because that was you know
the main reason I mean talk on the phone
with this thing what are you talking
about are you kidding you're basically
the only person I called you the other
day yeah yeah we talked on the phone and
so that summer maybe 1974 I made phone
calls that summer I would randomly call
people and say hey hi what are you doing
people like excuse me wait we didn't
text first that we were gonna plan to
talk yeah you called
like what's wrong you were just talking
crazy and I have to say the first two
weeks of that unplugging I would find
myself with my phone in my hand randomly
and I'd be like why is my phone in my
hand because I had I mean the
habituation of this thing is and that's
when I really started realizing oh we're
in deep [ __ ] I've already rewired my
brain to need this thing however often
you know and it was about two weeks
until I finally then would like lose my
phone all day in my house yeah I mean I
literally I know you know this but I
literally locked my phone in a safe in
August Wow because I didn't want to be
going to it now and I did not know the
code yep well I was just like that's how
we're gonna do this yeah and I avoided
screens of all kinds yes and news I mean
the whole thing and what I realized was
that my I felt truly that my brain was
resetting yeah and so what was like the
first few weeks for you like the first
couple days there's there's a level of
anxiety right there for sure like my
hand kept going to my pocket the way you
were describing with the table my hand
would just kick just to by default
because you know what reminded me of
that it's like if in the olden days you
know 15 years ago right if you were
gonna meet a friend at a bar right you
oh you call them you say alright I'll
meet you on the corner of you know 6th
and 14th ok
yeah well now if you go to 6 and 14th if
they are not there that second you would
meet yeah what are you doing yeah where
are you liking Instagram sure where are
you you're looking you're shopping all
these things you never just stop and
smell the roses yeah you never just stop
and stand there so what I realized was
the more that I got off there the more I
was I found even though I'm a pretty
patient person in general and I like
talking to people obviously I thought I
was nicer to cashiers at the market like
little little interactions like that I
found it wasn't the big ones yeah no I'm
pretty good at the big ones yeah but I
found that the little day-to-day ones
just being present more every time you
get out of your car to go to you know
buy a sandwich you stare your phone you
yeah just that ability to be present and
then the other thing was that when you
stopped doing it
you start looking at everyone else like
they're crazy when you see these people
and their necks I mean errs together no
one's looking at each other anymore and
you walk into a restaurant and nobody's
nobody just sits and just does this
anymore
like taking in people in the world no
one people watches and implements
anymore yeah no one people watches in
airports anymore so if we're not people
watching anymore and I believe people
watching is this beautiful way of
naturally finding a way to be in each
other's shoes you know like oh look at
that guy oh look he's wearing that oh
that Raider is t-shirt oh I'm a Raiders
fan only not you oh I but you're you're
having this internal dialogue with these
people and yes sometimes you're like
projecting you know [ __ ] on to them and
bias no I look at that big hair lady or
whatever you know but you're you're
having in a human encounter on some
level and we're social beings you know
this is ancient hard wiring this is not
hard wiring that even has caught up to
like 10,000 years ago like this is
ancient [ __ ] wiring here and we need
certain social cues and certain things I
I tweeted this morning about this that
we're if someone was like defending
social media which people do when I
always start to talk about this and I
say and I say you know but what if I can
talk to this person here in connection I
said yes yes yes yes I've met great
friends through social media and we are
not hard hardwired for the quantity of
interactions and the amount of
information coming into our brains so
what happens is and I've been studying a
lot about this is that we get into this
dopamine loop with it and it's like
heroin it just is the brain doesn't know
any better the brain just says I need
that thing again I need that thing again
I need that thing again yeah and if you
don't teach yourself to slow that down
or to be able to at least witness it
from afar and go oh look there's my hand
grabbing for the phone again or why am I
feeling so anxious oh because I haven't
checked my email in
three hours or whatever it is and you
learn to watch yourself and you learn to
see the cues of it and and then you go
and then you learn to sit with it and
notice that I don't know
you know you'd get the urge to pick up
the phone and then you'd watch it and
then five minutes later you're onto
something else yeah you don't you didn't
really need the phone in your hand the
whole time and so it's it's really
important because when we're in that
stimulated state we're kind of in this
drive state all the time and our bodies
in order to be healthy and our minds in
order to be healthy have to learn how to
be in a resting state like the
physiological resting state that's why
we sleep yeah you know and we're I mean
there's just one side effect but we're
we're overloading our poor bodies and
our poor minds 24/7 with this stuff and
then with the news cycle which I'm now
calling the news cycle it's not 24/7
it's 60 24 because every 60 minutes oh
and there's 24 hours of breaking news
but by breaking news usually they mean
they're just breaking news they're
actually breaking the way Alice's room
they're taking a big thing and they're
just hitting it ya know and they're just
saying the same thing they've been
saying for the last 24 hours and they're
calling it breaking news yeah but it's
the same thing oh it's new because you
know media relies on eyeballs and media
relies on you're missing something yeah
you better come look at us same thing
with Twitter so it's all the same yeah I
mean there's a lot they are even just I
mean you're right about the sleep part
of it because they've done studies about
yep if you look at your phone right
before bed you're gonna sleep yeah we're
Syfy you know I tried my other policies
now no phone in the bedroom yeah because
it shouldn't be the last thing you'll or
the first thing or I mean getting the
landlord the last thing I look at some
you know a Twitter avatar go [ __ ] your
toe Ruben then I wake up that's not a
good way to end your start the day you
know
yeah then and it the the interesting
thing is it's also how we relate I think
to positivity
so for example molten by and large most
of my interactions online actually I was
a huge percentage for all the trolls
that are out there args way positive
yeah people saying nice things and I
enjoy what you do and blah blah blah and
I'm on the ride with you and all that
good stuff but it's the bad ones that
you're like oh yeah that's somehow stay
with you which that shows you something
about how we relate positivity and
negative yeah yeah because you know
we're basically a little survivor beings
and in order to survive you have to be
alert for danger and so when a negative
event happens or something negative
comes towards you the brain processes
that and puts it in a memory bank
different than positive things that's
why everyone's had a shitty childhood
but it is it's banked differently inside
of your brain and it sticks with you
differently and yeah it's I started one
of the things I preach these days is a
gratitude practice mm-hmm and it's
something I teach in my classes and I'm
reading this amazing book right now
showing that you know it's it's that
gratitude and compassion and a certain
aspect of pride are three emotions that
will help you stick to long-term goals
way more efficiently than willpower or
your rational executive mind and
decision-making and and they have found
that gratitude creates a different
wiring in your brain that allows you to
be more present in your body and it's
more it creates more empathy for
yourself and for your future self mm-hmm
and you actually are more like I said
more efficient when you have gratitude
more gratitude in your life and it's so
in this and it's such a hippie woo thing
yeah it's really not what do you think
the relationship with is with that to
empathy because that it seems to me that
we're the peak we're getting the
dopamine hit ya where we you know you
can on any given morning you can open up
Twitter find someone halfway across the
world that you've never heard of who
said something you mile
disagree with right and now you can
destroy their life you know you can drag
the Twitter mob and destroy this yeah
and now obviously I try not to do that
sort of thing but it shows a certain lat
it's not just you're getting the
dopamine oh I got five retweets because
I attacked this idiot that I've never
heard of before it's also shows just
this disconnect yeah between what humans
are because you know and in 99.9% of the
interactions people have online they
would not do this to the person's face
and I that's one of things I really try
to do I really try and I'm sure I fail
at it and I'm sure I found that I used
to fail at it more but that I will not
tweet something that I would not say to
someone's face if they were right yeah
yeah and it's something I if rarely when
I get a troll I rarely do but when I do
I will say would you say that to my face
and they disappear very quickly yes
compassion and empathy are things that
we have to work at and having a metal
object in your hand with just words on
it I think is your brain is and I don't
know the science behind this and I'd be
fascinated to find out more about it but
I think your brain is engaging with it
in a way because it's an object and it's
words on a page so it's language it's
going through a certain part of your
brain where where is empathy in
connection with humans is a felt
experience it's it's a different thing
you know I mean one of the things we do
with Buddhist practice you know there's
two major things with Buddhist practice
one of which is or just meditation or
mindfulness in general you can take the
Buddhism out of it is learning to
witness and watch things your thoughts
your feelings you know whatever but it's
it's learning to take a witness stance
and watch this ever-changing parade
inside of you go by urges sensations all
that kind of stuff so that's one thing
that mindfulness meditation will help
you rewire your brain to do that and
when you get some distance from things
you get to be in choice more about them
because you're not just react
acting you're actually responding to
them the other thing that happens
organically with this practice is an
increased sense of compassion there's
some sort of human connection that
happens where the circle of who you care
about naturally widens mm-hmm and that
there's and there's and labels drop off
because it becomes sentient beings or
living beings you know and we all know
how to do this in like lover family
tribe neighborhood city football team
you know like we have these like groups
that we can do this with political party
in this country right now is a big thing
that kind of stuff but there's something
about the practice of including all
sentient beings in this and one of the
practices you do in loving-kindness
which I always loved when I first
learned it was in the early aughts
during the Bush Cheney years not a fan
of the bush cheney team but they would
ask you to first she'd meditate on
someone that is kind of someone you love
automatically the easiest thing is your
pet like the thing that like greets you
at the door goes I love you and like you
you you think about you think about this
person in your mind and this big warm
heart thing happens those were humans
that's what happens to us all the oxygen
oxytocin and all that stuff and then you
like think about someone neutral you
know the person at Vons who checks the
thing and I see her every week and oh
I'm just gonna like have happy thoughts
about her and then I say now bring
someone in who you don't like mm-hmm you
know and you can do whatever scale you
need to do maybe Dick Cheney's not the
person to start with the bully in high
school who the bully in high school
right or the guy at work who just
irritates you a little bit and let this
person be in your circle of loving
kindness and let yourself see that this
person wakes up every single day looking
for happiness just like you are looking
to have some
of success some human connection you
know unless they're sociopaths I guess
or a narcissist
those are both on the rise I don't I
think they're I think they are I think
we're just I think we're seeing it more
right it's more it's more apparent but
to really see that this person a you
know puts their pants on one leg at a
time and that they really care for their
children and that they are in their own
way doing what they feel is best for the
world especially people in power you
know they really wake up thinking I you
know I mean there are some I've met some
people who really don't give a [ __ ]
about the world right and are just very
greedy and just want to make as much
money as possible third people like that
on every scope but most people are
waking up hoping the world would be a
better place and that they'll make some
human connection with it yeah and when
at least you can I don't know entertain
that thought then then it's easier to I
don't know not take a mallet to people
instantly you know and I mean for me
during the campaign and you and I talked
about this a lot we talked about the
pain of the traditional white male in
America and how for 50 years because
because of the how the progress of
culture feminism and civil rights
movement and all this kind of things a
lot of people who've been silenced for a
long time and oppressed for a long time
had gotten their voice and now after 40
or 50 years there's a part of the
population more traditional white male
who feel that the world is leaving them
behind and when they look out in the
media
they don't see themselves represented
much they don't see their voice and
their politicians because of money and
corruption aren't seeing them also and
what I have been thinking about lately
is wouldn't it be amazing if all of us
women myself who I'm thrilled about this
I mean you know people caught can call
me a social justice warrior I don't know
if I fit in that category but yes I'm a
woman who's looking to have my voice
bigger in the world thank god they're
[ __ ] talking about sexual harassment
now and all that [ __ ]
black people people of color Latino gays
buys trans all of us who are getting a
voice now and have had a voice to
empathically turn our hearts towards
those who feel invisible and silenced
and to say we see you hmm
and we hear you and let's have a
conversation because we know what it's
like oh my god and that that would be
the heart of this thing that it seems to
be missing because for the because I
always try not to impugn people's
intentions yeah I always I agree with
what you said earlier that to me most
people even when they're doing bad
things wake up they don't think I'm out
there I'm gonna start doing bad things
today yeah you know I didn't mean like
they probably thought he was a good guy
yeah yeah evidence to believe that he
did I don't so I try not to impugn
people's motives but the hard part's
interesting here because there's a lot
of look you should have equal I think
most same thinking people we should have
equal opportunity for everybody we can't
wait we can't at least in this country
that's what we're fighting for right is
like an opportunity equal opportunity
equal voice yeah these things are kind
of written into the Constitution right
but you can't then you know then the
results of that may not always be the
same but that's then partly on you and
partly on luck and all the other things
and work ethic and all that right but
the hard part is interesting here
because if this movement that I spend so
much time talking about that I think is
so toxic that I think is destroying so
much of the fabric of the country if it
had a little bit yeah what you're
talking about I think it would do a
world of good and unfortunately I don't
see any sign of it well I think that I
think it's because it wants it so bad or
something well something like that yeah
you know and being you know being a
progressive lefty myself and I can
certainly step into the shoes of someone
who wants to put their fists up and say
you know [ __ ] the man and [ __ ] all that
you know like I get that energy I grew
up on that in the 60s and 70s I was fed
on that stuff you know my dad was an
anti-authoritarian guy you know
and who railed against the white male in
this country my entire life
so but it's interesting when I even if I
we were to watch all of your dad's
specials after this and watch his stuff
about the white man it didn't have the
tone that this stuff has now I don't
think I guess this is maybe his personal
life too I mean he would sit in first
class and he would just be disgusted by
the average white male businessman
sitting next to him in first class like
he had a real chip on his shoulder but I
think that was his personal chip also
cause of where he came from but I think
also and and you and I've talked a
little bit about this and it because I
kind of like to look at this movement
this progressive movement through the
eyes of kind of integral philosophy also
which is that there is this movement
that has that is the leading edge of the
culture and the leading edge of a
culture is always about widening
widening voices widening opportunities
taking people you know widening the
empathy game but the problem is is that
this progressive culture sees people in
the what they call the modern culture
and integral thinking which is
capitalism and you know rational
thinking secularism and then there's the
traditional people one church one God
don't take my guns all that kind of
stuff and so it's blue orange and green
those are the three kind of memes and
the problem is that these three people
refuse to see each other as humans and I
think there are those of us who are
stepping outside of all of this and say
hey guess what we're all humans and your
and your your kind of you know pointing
at each other saying you're not humans
and you are and I think it is the
ultimate blind spot of this
progressivism is that they they they
instantly see anyone who's not like them
as evil which is ironic because they are
themselves owning their difference in
the world and so it is a strange kind of
little Jedi
mind trick on people with this thing and
but I do think that when the funny thing
is though when I talk to people off of
social media and people day-to-day and
friends and everything and I mention
this to people they all agree with me
yeah they say like yeah you know people
are really you know they hold like when
we talk about political correctness
that's how they really get it I say you
know they're there they're talking about
tolerance but they're actually using
intolerance you know with a shield of
Tolerance in front of them and they
don't see the own trick they're doing to
themselves and but people really are
getting that more and more I think your
message is getting out yeah I think it
is yeah because I think people are fed
up with and I think that's the exciting
time that we're in right now is that
it's really messy so in a weird way I've
asked this of many guests I know what
you feel about Trump not a fan loudly
but in a weird way yes we have to thank
him for them completely because a sushi
unless unless the world blows up
tomorrow right right that would not be
good okay yeah there's some policy
things not happy with yeah but a hundred
percent and I've been saying that to
people lately and and some of the
progressives they do get a little scared
when I say this I've said it to a bunch
of people at your party because it's
like we would have not had this talk
about racism in our country the way
we've had it messy loud it's on the
[ __ ] table women would not have taken
this to the streets and say I'd really
believe the me to movement would have
not gotten the traction it has right now
without this person to push up against
and this thing to push up against you
know and this is the way culture works
it swings one way and then a force comes
in to push up against it and it swings
the other way and at some point we start
to work this [ __ ] out and the other
thing too that we can thank him for is
even though it's scary out there in
conversation land and it's a lot of
yelling and I mean that's part of the
reason I know you and I get off this
social media thing is because it's just
it's panic on both sides it's yeah it's
pure [ __ ] panic all the time and and
it's not just it's not just average
people know or that sounds so whatever
but it's not just the average person
that's tweeting that doesn't really know
about things I don't know that people
that that are really bright authors and
professors that better history panic
yeah panicked about things and and so
you know yeah I get it it's it's scary
but the fact that Trump doesn't play by
the rules rhetorically certainly the
political establishment thing is it's
interesting to watch him
fumble his way into policy but the fact
that he's kind of breaking all the rules
is I think in the end like you said if
nothing really bad happens is gonna make
this democracy more resilient in the end
because we're learning to speak truth to
each other again instead of that
politicians speak which is really
refreshing these days when you go on
whoever you're watching if you're
watching media cable news right left I
don't know what CNN is anymore when
politicians come on no matter what
there's a lot less of that speeches
macspeech speech happening where they
really they say like 200 words but
they've said absolutely nothing huh
there's a lot less of that going on I
think that's a good thing for the
culture in the end and it's teaching us
also I mean me I you know people can
read my book I grew up being the
diplomat you know mom and dad are trying
to kill each other
yeah and I'm like that's everyone just
tap it down
I'll hold hands little kumbaya please
but I am learning to tolerate that in
change comes chaos and when we're gonna
re you know Systems Theory
this is Systems Theory in order for a
system to change there needs to be some
dissonance happening yeah and so we're
getting that and it's not fun to be in
it's not fun to be in but there's a
richness there and it and yeah there
it's fun or not there's a necessity then
there is there is and I'm not a burn it
all down person for the right or the
left i I'm sorry I want food on the
market show yeah I do like my TV and my
internet you know you think the burn it
down crowd I think I think part it's
just bravado and it's especially its
online idealism on some level it's an
idea yeah so there's a little secrecy
yeah okay so some idealism I suppose
some some just online whatever but for
some of them it's also just like in a
way it's like the easiest thing to say
right yeah like to just be like burn it
all down it's like where do you want to
go yeah nobody like what does it mean
nobody nobody yeah
it's same people who want open borders
here right are the same people who are
screaming how horrible it is here and
yet yeah we can't have open borders and
they don't leave Lena Dunham still here
HBO show does she really um see so I
don't know what that right exactly so
she ain't going anywhere
yeah we're all we're all here we're all
we all got to figure this out together
and every both sides have legitimate
beefs
about institutions hundred-percent and
how business is done in the world 100%
but yeah to burn it all down it is it's
like you know instead of having the big
talk with your boyfriend it's the
leaving the note and just ghosting yeah
and yet so and and that you're just
gonna replicate again do it again and
again because you haven't had this part
yet you haven't had the uneasy part you
know where we were we where we have all
of us have to own our own [ __ ] as
grown-ups yeah and we have to tell the
world what we need also at this
time both of those things need to happen
what do you make of the crew of people
that I think mostly are online now you
know Eric Weinstein who's been out here
a bunch of times calls it the
intellectual dark web but just this
group of people who are trying to do
this who come from all over the place so
you've got lefties a a theist lefties
like Sam eros who are now allies with
right-wing conservatives that are
believers like ben shapiro you know I
mean and yet they're allies it's a
beautiful thing it's incredible isn't it
it is yeah
it is watching establishment I mean just
from watching the campaign you know
watching establishment Republicans who
worked for camp you know establishment
candidates for years getting their own
show on MSNBC it's a yeah it's like and
so it's so it's Alice in Wonderland it
really is up is down down is up you know
you just follow Trump's Twitter account
and you get that like just see what he
tweeted six years ago and now he'll do
the opposite thing well that's why I
keep saying for all the people that are
so frazzled by him I just get he's
they're all liars he's just doing it a
different way but most of the things
even the things on immigration
yeah you can literally I mean to people
that don't believe me check it on
YouTube right now you can find video of
Bill Clinton and Obama saying almost the
exact same things on immigration and
protecting borders and all that Trump
says it in a much less articulate way
and he uses obviously rough language and
but it's like you're all liars yes and I
think that one of the things that may
may or may not be true I don't know
these people personally but I think
there's like my dad used to say he
always voted people over property so
that's why he would always lean left
mm-hmm
because he always would choose people
over property and I think in general
that's what the left does is they choose
people over property and whereas the
right generally chooses the right to be
in control of your own property versus
taking care of people like that's a
secondary that's a fair yeah and and and
the reality is we we do both mmm
all day long it's how we [ __ ] those are
the two kind of things we function on
right is is that and so I think in you
know on some level yes if you pay
attention to the words and see the
policies and stuff like that there are
ways in which Obama and Clinton and
Trump kind of sit in a kind of a pool
somewhere but there's a I think the
Trump thing for me is that there's a
level of pathology in him that frightens
me because I really don't know except
for his clothes people around him I
don't think he knows how to have empathy
for anyone who doesn't go to Mara Lago
which ain't cheap I think is part of
what you're saying yeah and and he just
doesn't I mean if you know anything
about his childhood he was tortured by
his father I mean mentally tortured by
this by this child you know and so he's
a person who's been shaped by his
experiences and he's got a you know I
mean I've studied psychology he's got a
form of narcissism that's scary now you
have to be a narcissist to run for
president yeah I mean my dad was a
narcissist you have to be a narcissist
to be a stand-up comedian you know you
but there's a healthy level of
narcissism and then there's like there's
the level that just sort of makes the
world work best realist wouldn't won you
I have a vision I believe in it maybe no
one else does I'm going up if I'm gonna
do it and oh look it's working kind of a
thing but but you see in his
thin-skinned 'add new stuff like that
you know that's what worries me is that
kind of stuff like basing policy on a
person with that kind of personality
makeup you know say what Bill Clinton is
or Obama I think they're pretty empathic
human beings yeah it's interesting a lot
of my audience that's watching this will
probably go they'll go well wait a
minute Scott Adams who was on here said
it's all a sideshow while he's actually
getting things done and I think there's
a lot of truth to that too and that's
part of the problem right now I don't
it's kind of hard to figure out
thing he's that organized yeah I really
don't I think he is getting things done
because he's got people doing things but
um I think he I don't think his
personalities that organized to do I
mean look at his businesses they've all
failed he's a bankrupt businessman so
that's Trump water you're drinking you
know fYI I have stayed at Trump hotels
all right I want to finish up with this
was a quick 55 so much it's always hit
but I promise it will not be to
interfere so we do this but I thought it
would be an interesting thing to finish
up on you studied Jungian archetypes
yes and Jordan Peterson who is basically
caught fire like nobody else in the last
year it's one of the he talks about
archetypes constantly so I thought it
would be interesting to kind of unpack a
little bit yeah that with you
yeah because so much my audience is into
it I think it's it's helped frame some
things in in my own mind first off what
possessed you to say I'm gonna study
Jungian architects
yeah well Joseph Campbell was a great
mythologist a great storyteller and I
saw him on PBS with bill Moyer and fell
in love with this idea of just these
this idea that we are all kind of
pre-wired for story and then we all are
we're pre-wired to understand what a
mother is and a father and a child and
because of humanity's long ancientness
you know we've kind of lived these
things out and so it sort of births
the whole human experience sort of
births these ideas that then are sort of
built into a hundred percent
yeah we're it's it's kind of like
shortcuts
inside of us in some ways and then Young
and Joseph Campbell studied some young
and learned that and about the
collective unconscious and the personal
unconscious and all of that which Freud
talked about but Jung was the collective
unconscious and so I I I was fascinated
a with the storytelling aspect of young
so young as a man who you know talks
about archetypes and how they run us and
how they shape our narrative and how
they shape our culture and but he also
talked about how one of the archetypes
we have is this relationship to the
sacred and relationship to the numinous
which is the arc
called the self with a big s he would
write it and it is this hardwiring we
have to that sense of like you know
people get when like you go out in
nature and you feel at one with
everything or people feel about Jesus or
feel about all our you know if you're
more traditional religion it manifests
in very different ways and I was really
fascinated by that I wanted to
understand the human condition
personally I wanted to work on my own
stuff psychologically but I wanted to
understand like what makes humans tick
and how come this all it all unfolds
like this you know and and what's the
story line behind the story line the
culture hands us all day that's my
fascination that's why I look at all of
this right left all this kind of stuff
more from an an archetypal perspective
or more of a philosophical perspective
because it helps me not get caught up in
the churning of it all oh yeah yeah just
I thought we just knock out a couple of
yeah the archetypes because it's just an
interesting way of looking at things
so the persona I mean that basically the
the sort of it's really just the face
that we put on publicly that can't
always show every bit of ourselves even
though some of us are better at it
yeah and others in some are horrible
it's the one you're trained day one so
day one you're born and the minute you
can walk and talk you're at some point
your parent says don't do that Dave and
you take that little part of you that
maybe he's like wants to like dance like
a wild woman and you put it in a bag
behind you and you start taking these
parts and the teacher says you just sit
down and oh and look I got A's oh I know
how to do that now and you start only
putting forward the parts that get
approval and love or get some sort of
energy for you that make you feel like
who you are so yeah your persona becomes
this identity now the thing about the
persona is though you've got all this
stuff in the bag that you're driving
you're dragging around behind you Robert
Bly wrote a great essay about this the
long dress the long bag we dragged
behind us and those are your shadow
elements another archetypal so those are
the parts that we go I don't like that
that one's not okay and most of the time
it's our culture our
our institutions our families telling us
the parts to put away so your persona is
almost built on running from your shadow
100% yes exactly and where we all get
into trouble as we start to believe that
this is who we are and yet there's all
of these voices and narratives and urges
inside of us that need a voice also yeah
and then they pop out in unexpected
horrible weird strange ways addictions
depression anxiety obsessions fetishes
whatever it is and the more we can pull
these shadow parts out and sit with them
and say oh like for me rage is one of my
shadow parts my parents rage at each
other I said I will never be a rager the
rest of my life well not getting angry
is not a healthy thing
murder is raged okay I get it probably
shouldn't go there yeah generally but
damn it I have the right to [ __ ] be
pissed off about things and to say no to
the world and feel it feel that natural
emotion I've had to learn to pick that
out of my bag and say all right I get to
be angry you know so yeah it's
interesting because people see me the
way I conduct an interview and I'm
obviously pretty even-keeled and
pleasant natured and all that and then
sometimes when we do a live stream when
it's just me to the camera I'm a little
more animated I'll curse a little bit
more I'll be a little bit maybe more the
way a friend would know me right and
then sometimes people will meet me in
real life if I you know somebody comes
up to me at a bar and I'm completely
different and it's like those are still
all pieces of none of them are fake
pieces right they're all just different
yeah because we because we know roles -
I mean right you know by day I'm a
teacher by night I'm a wife sometimes
you know whatever it is and when you're
a stand-up comedian when you go up into
your comedy that's a different day I'm
sitting here right now you know but and
they're not it doesn't mean exactly that
you're fake or anything like that but
the more the more you can I think be
more of yourself in different situations
you know I mean obviously skills aside
the more whole you feel in general so
the another one of these is the animal
animus which is basically the the male
and female or the right so that's the
shadow within each of us so for me it's
my inner masculine and for you it's your
inner feminine mm-hmm and basically
we're taught by culture and everything
to be just one thing but and the word
masculine and feminine is really
unfortunate that's why I think Jung used
anima and animus because it's more about
oppositional energies one is more about
doing one is more about being one is
more about charging into the world the
others about more receiving the world
and it's so it's about different ways of
learning to be in the world and the
feminine in general has an aspect to it
an archetypal aspect to it
mother sister goddess you know you think
about all that the masculine warrior you
know it doesn't mean a woman can't be a
warrior but she's tapping into her urn
or in her masculine when she does that
yeah so it's interesting that you said
those words are unfortunate because you
can see it right now where everyone
wants us to think we're all the same
like we have no biological differences
right I have no chemical differences
which is absolutely insane it's insane
biologically and it's it's insane
evolution doesn't mean that we don't
have equal access equal rights of stuff
but I mean each of us bring something
different and one of the things that I
love about being a woman and being a
feminist right now and you know when I
talk about the patriarchy I talk about
it in such a way it's like there's one
way of looking at the world that doesn't
always work that that holds the world in
a certain way and women have a different
way of looking at the world you get a
roomful of women together they organized
very differently than men do
and and this natural way maybe the world
needs a little more of that feminine way
and that that's why we women want more
power in the world not the way the power
the structure is now but a way like that
we can change the way power is in the
world you know and it's messy and
complicated and but yeah it it can be
confusing I
that's the right way to end this it can
be confusing that it can be confusing
that way alright but really more than
anything else I just wanted to say that
the reason I wanted have you on for this
was just because I was off last week and
we pre-taped some stuff and I'm sitting
on the beach I was trying to like figure
out like how do how do i how do i evolve
now past what i'm doing and how do i
figure out other ways and you're one of
the people that i consistently can talk
to about this stuff and that will admit
that you don't have all the answers
while everyone else is screaming
constantly all the answers yeah and i
find that usually those are the people
who actually have the least not the most
so we will we will do this it will not
be to in it oh good I would love to see
that and you know you're funny you
mentioned the love of the dog but yeah
before your dog Stella's a little
bananas yes but you have great love for
her and that shows that you are she
reflects my inner bananas alright guys I
hope you enjoyed the livestream for more
on Kelly
well first off she's teaching these
webinars in all sources of your site is
Kelly garlic on right yes are you gonna
send them to your Twitter but after all
we just talked about it on my website
and I'm actually starting another class
April first if people are interested in
signing up so there you go to me Kelly
Carlin comm new class on April 1st all
right thanks
you